all right while we're on the subject of
artificial intelligence parents beware
because as we know AI can create images
sound video that's so realistic it's
hard to tell what's real from what's
fake AI generated nude photos were
circulated around a New Jersey high
school using faces of young female
students now you can only imagine how
emotionally shattering this would be to
girls who were victimized by these sorts
of deep fakes we're told that this
happened to dozens of girls including my
next guest 14-year-old Franchesca Manny
she alerted the principal after she
found out that one of the nudes was
using her face she's also with her mom
DOA Mani Franchesca first of all thank
you so much for telling your story how
did you find out about this so basically
the principal um informed me that I was
one of many AI victims and and after
that I just felt like betrayed cuz I
never thought it'd be my classmate and
when I came home I told my mom and I
said we need to do something about this
because it's not okay and people are
making it seem like it
is well how did it make you feel I mean
did you actually see the images or you
just heard about them no I didn't get to
see them it made me feel very betrayed
and I just felt very uncomfortable
knowing
that he was walking like the hallways of
my school and I just don't think it's
okay uh DOA um do you know if any of
these images stayed local of your
daughter so to speak or did did you ask
the school principal if the images made
it anywhere else online to the extent
that they could track them right well
very good question as per the email that
uh the principal sent out the images are
gone as per the conversation that I had
over the phone with the vice principal
the images are gone and I should not
worried because it was just a Snapchat
it was distributed through snapchat um
so you know I know there's such a thing
as digital footprint that lasts forever
um and even though there have been
distributed through snapchat they are
somewhere out there so we are fighting
right now to figure it out um where and
how to retrive them and through this
whole process we've been so disappointed
in the way that Westfield High School
has been handling this uh situation for
all the girls well yeah so we haven't
confirmed how many people this actually
happened to or how many people we don't
know how many people saw these images I
presume you don't either uh but it
sounds like you're thinking of filing a
lawsuit if you know as a former lawyer
it kind of sounds like that's where this
is headed um how could can the school
actually control or why would you say it
controlled the Snapchat accounts of
students right that's their does corre
right that's their approach they believe
that you know I didn't do it it was not
on my device it was not on my premises
but but as per the um cyber harassment
policies um this should have not
happened and there should have been
consequences so it's a little bit more
than just you know kids sending pictures
of a snap on the Snapchat right um
there's a bigger issue here there's a
bullying there's um cyber harassment and
there's the administration who is
pretending that nothing has happened
there's administrations that are not
listening to the girls um that have been
victimized and other girls who feel this
is not okay and who feel um they feel
uncomfortable they feel traumatized they
feel hurt they feel betrayed and nobody
listens to them yesterday actually let
me add one thing Franchesca have you
talked to the other I'm I'm sorry I'm
GNA ask your daughter if you don't mind
Franchesca have you talked to a lot of
the other girls or do you know their
names your fellow students to whom this
also happened their again their faces
were put on nudes that were then
circulated according to these reports on
Snapchat have you spoken to them yes I
have they feel extremely uncomfortable
knowing that he's in our school they're
also really mad that the school's not
really doing anything about it and not
trying to help this
situation and they're just mad that they
do you know who did it um Franchesca are
you aware of who did it or do you have a
good idea of who did it yeah don't say
the name I don't want to hear the name
but do you have a good idea of who did
it yes I
do oh you do okay well seems like that's
kind of where the where the liability
lies um Franchesca uh and uh d
any type of cyber bullying cyber stalk
any of this uh involving students these
deep fakes it's horrific thank you very
much for speaking out we really
appreciate it thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else